let's move it to the next one this is
jamal adams the seahawks really just an
ugly finish to the season and this was
adams after a loss to the rams
yeah just i guess jamal how
disappointing is this your first playoff
game and
to make a quick exit like this how hard
is it on you
yeah it's tough man um you know
obviously you know this is this wasn't
the plan right but you know we can we
can come up with a million and one
excuses but
the fact of the matter we're not gonna
do it you know what i mean um you know a
lot
had to go off to you know la
they did a phenomenal job um they
controlled the clock and
um they flipped the field on us a lot of
times and made more plays than we did
um and you know it's tough to you know
uh win ball games when we're not hitting
on all cylinders
all three phases and um you know
the marathon continues man we'll be back
you know it's not the end of the world
um obviously you know our season is cut
short but we got to learn from it
um and get healthy and come back next
year you know
swinging on all cylinders i'd sit back
jack and i look at this
offense and the defense is going to be
fine jamal adams he's going to get
healthy have a couple surgeries they're
going to continue to add pieces i like
what they've done from a defensive side
they're no longer that conservative
defense just cover three they blitz they
do a whole bunch of different things
but if i'm looking at offensively i
don't know if they need to find a new
offense coordinator if they need to
bring it a passing coordinator
but russell wilson needs discipline and
he is the problem
he is the problem you know why russell
wilson is a problem because he needs
discipline
he does whatever he wants he drops back
and it's all this is what their offense
is about
drop back run around and try to find
someone deep
no no that that doesn't work in the
playoffs that doesn't work
all the time yeah it can work and you
know you can make a lot of big plays
during the regular season but when you
come to the playoffs and you're trying
to win a championship
that type of offense is not going to
work and you saw seattle get exposed
this last month and you look at russell
wilson he goes from mvp to 11 for 27
you know uh interception and 174 yards
passing in the playoffs
this it's it's absolutely crazy russell
needs to stop doing his own thing and
they need to hone him in a little bit
and and not treat him like a rookie
anything like that
but he needs more discipline he needs
more discipline because i think they
give him too much freedom
and it and it's it's not working out for
him
offense got caught in no man's land they
went from a running offense that would
rely on russ leighton games to come back
make magic and win the game
to a russ cook offense that was all
about russ all the time and then lost
the running game
and then they ended up in absolutely
nowhere they just didn't know who they
were
they got to the playoffs it's not like
the rams played a good game offensively
rams were bad
offensively really and they still did
enough to beat the seattle offense and
jamal adams played great all year and
he's
he's so awesome down around the line of
scrimmage and he does things that we
haven't seen
i've said this on the show before since
troy paloma in my opinion
but he had a chance for an easy
interception in that game
it's just a lollipop interception and
he's really not
great at playing the ball in the air
that's not the strength of his
game and that would have been a
game-changing play i mean it was just
floating in the air he's right there
turning his hips around to go catch it
and he didn't and ends up getting
completed i believe i've watched a lot
of football this weekend but i do
believe it ended up getting complete i
know he didn't pick it
right in behind him so yeah i'm glad
that jamal adams is there it was a blast
watching him play it seems like all we
really even talked about with the
seattle defense they have bobby wagner
all those studs and all we talked about
all year long
was jamal adams i slayed down to his
performance was this the right move they
gave up a lot to go get this man
to bring him in there to seattle
absolutely you see how much the defense
improved and with a guy that plays with
so much emotion
and plays so physical you see even bobby
wagner raise his
level of game um carlos dunlap jaron
reed
he's you know he's had about eight or
nine sacks this year
yeah i mean jamal great players make
other guys better and he's an unselfish
guy i text him all the time
they'll be fine they just got to get
russell honed in a little bit more
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports